We already had a video with an overview of DNA,
I recommend you look at him first.
And in this clip
we will deepen a little more
in the molecular structure of DNA.
This is the starting point.
Let's first remember what DNA means.
I will write the different parts of the word
in different colors.
DNA means deoxy,
deoxyribonucleic acid,
ribonucleic,
ribonucleic acid.
Ribonucleic acid.
We will leave this aside
and we will look at the molecular structure of DNA
and how it is related to the name,
deoxyribonucleic acid.
The DNA consists of bound nucleic acids,
and the term nucleus comes from the fact,
that these acids are found in the nucleus.
They are in the nucleus of eukaryotes.
Here comes "nucleic".
In a second we'll explain
why is acid called.
Each DNA molecule consists of a chain
of nucleotides.
From the so-called nucleotides.
It is composed of a nucleus -
nucleotides.
What does a nucleotide look like?
That's it
two DNA strands that are increased.
I've increased the two DNA strands.
You can see the right one here,
as well
the backbone of one half of the double chain.
This is the other half of the double chain,
and here we have bridges,
I will talk about what molecules they are.
They are like the steps of the ladder.
I will now separate one nucleotide.
Nucleotide is ...
that part, which
I outline here,
she is
nucleotide.
This is a nucleotide,
which is connected to another.
It is linked to another nucleotide.
Another nucleotide here.
On the right side we have a nucleotide,
we have a nucleotide here.
Actually, I'll do it
slightly different.
We have a nucleotide here on the right
and we have another one at the bottom right.
We have another nucleotide.
Here are four nucleotides.
These two are on the left side of the ladder,
and these two are on the right side of the ladder.
Now let's think about
different parts of the nucleotide.
One thing that can make an impression on you
are these phosphate groups.
This is a phosphate group here.
This is a phosphate group.
Each of these nucleotides has a phosphate group.
This is a phosphate group here
and this is a phosphate group.
Phosphate groups are what makes DNA -
or what makes nucleic acids, acids.
You can say, "Wait, wait."
"Sal, you have your drawing"
"negative charge."
"Something with a negative charge will attract protons,"
"will accept protons."
"How can it be acid?"
"It looks like a foundation."
The reason why DNA is depicted
with these negative charges,
that it is so acidic that if put in
in a neutral solution,
will lose its hydrogen atoms.
In fact, if we want to be fully correct,
DNA molecules will have,
protonated phosphate groups such as this.
But they so much want to release these hydrogen protons,
that usually -
Will get rid of the negative charge here.
Woops.
Only this phosphate group here.
If we get rid of the negative charge,
and if it was connected
with hydrogen.
That's what you want to take these electrons so much.
This oxygen atom can take these electrons
and then this hydrogen will be attached
to a water molecule for example.
Thus the proton will be released.
That's why we call DNA acid.
If it was not in solution, there would be attached hydrogen atoms,
but it would be very acidic and as soon as it was put in
neutral solution will lose those hydrogen atoms.
Phosphate groups make DNA
acid,
but sometimes it can be confusing,
when you see it, depicted
with these negative charges.
They are there because the DNA has already lost its hydrogen protons.
In addition, here we depict a related basis,
but from the phosphate group comes the acid name.
In the beginning it was protonated,
but easily loses its hydrogen atoms.
From here
the acid name comes.
Each of these nucleotides has a phosphate group.
The next thing you might notice -
The next thing you can see is
this group here.
She is cyclic, has a ring
and terribly much like sugar,
this is because it is sugar.
This sugar has a five-carbon ring.
What I've pictured here, this sugar, is ribose.
This sugar is ribose.
Ribose in its linear form.
It, like many sugars, can also take a cyclical form.
In fact, it can take many different cyclic forms,
but this is most often described.
I will number the carbon atoms,
because that's important,
when we talk about DNA.
If we start with the carbonyl group here,
we call this carbon atom number one or one primacy.
One prim, two prim, three priam,
four prim and five prim.
This is a carbon atom of five primes.
We can form the cyclic form of ribose
with the oxygen atom -
this one here is connected
with a carbon atom four.
He uses one of his free electronic pairs,
uses one of his free electronic pairs,
to form a bond.
To make a connection with
carbon atom a prim.
I drew it so,
because the molecule bends.
The whole molecule will bend this way,
to form a cyclic structure.
When this relationship is formed,
the carbon can release one of these double bonds,
which then can be
used from oxygen.
The oxygen atom can use these electrons,
to attract hydrogen proton,
to capture a hydrogen proton.
When this happens, we get this form.
In this form, for the sake of clarity,
this is a carbon atom a primacy.
One prim, two prim, three priam,
four prim and five prim.
Where we see this relationship,
at a carbon atom a preference,
which was part of a carbonyl group.
Now he has freed himself from one of these double bonds.
This oxygen can form a bond
with a hydrogen proton.
He releases one double link here,
so it can form a hydrogen bonding proton.
This hydrogen proton is
this hydrogen proton here.
This green link,
between four carbon and
and the oxygen bound
with carbon atoms four and one,
this is here.
Here's the link here.
This oxygen is that oxygen.
Note that this oxygen is associated with four carbons,
and now with a carbon atom a primacy.
It is also linked to hydrogen.
It is linked to hydrogen,
with this hydrogen atom.
But it can be attracted by
molecule of water, to convert a hydroxone cation
and be lost.
Takes a hydrogen proton from here
and can thus lose a hydrogen proton.
Overall, this is not a profit or a loss.
We form a cyclical form
and the cyclic form here
is very close to what we see in the DNA molecule.
In fact, what we see in the RNA molecule,
in ribonucleic acid.
What do you think it is about,
when we talk about deoxyribonucleic acid.
We can start with ribose here,
but if we get rid of one of the oxygen groups
and in particular from -
In fact, if we just get rid of one of the oxygen atoms,
and substitutes the hydroxyl group only with hydrogen,
we will get deoxyribose
right here.
This is a five-membered ring,
with four carbon atoms,
it looks like that.
Carbon-related hydrogen atoms are understood to mean,
we have seen this many times.
Carbon atoms are at the intersections of these lines
or on the corners, or perhaps
at the end of the lines.
We can see -
If we compare these two molecules,
if we compare these two molecules here,
we see that this atom has -OH,
This atom has -OH and -H.
By default, this carbon atom is linked to two hydrogen atoms.
It has no connection with oxygen.
This is deoxyribose.
Deoxyribose.
Deoxyribose has no oxygen,
it does not have oxygen
at carbon atom two moiety.
So if we remove this oxygen atom, we get deoxyribose.
Let me surround it.
This here
is deoxyribose.
Deoxy - deoxyribose,
before we connect it to these other monomers.
This is deoxyribose.
Here comes a deoxyrib
and then the last part,
the last part of this piece - is here.
This is called the nitrogen base.
Nitrogen.
Nitrogen bases.
We have different types of nitrogen bases.
This is a nitrogen base.
This is another nitrogen base here.
This is another different nitrogen base here.
Note that this one has only one ring, this one has a ring,
but this one has two.
This one here has two rings.
Accordingly, we have different names
for these nitrogen bases.
Those with two rings in total
are called purine bases (purines).
Two-ring nitrogenous bases,
are called purines.
This is a common classification term.
I'll write it - purrins.
If we have one ring.
I'll write it like that.
One ring.
Bases with a ring are called pyrimidines (pyrimidines).
Pyrimidine.
Pyrimidines.
We call them pyrimidine bases.
Especially these two, on the right,
these two purine bases,
this is adenine,
we talked about how they connect
in the general DNA clip.
Here is adenine,
this nitrogen base.
This is guanine here.
This is guanine.
And then here,
this nitrogen base has a single ring,
which makes it pyrimidine, and is thymine.
This is a thymin here.
This is thymine. Last but not least,
if we are not talking about DNA,
and for RNA, we have uracil.
But when we talk about DNA,
this is cytosine here.
Cytosine.
You can see his structure.
Timmin is attracted to adenine.
It is associated with adenine,
and cytosine binds to guanine.
How do they connect?
The way these nitrogen bases
form the stairs of the ladder
is through our good old friends, hydrogen bonds.
All this happens because
nitrogen is very electronegative.
When nitrogen is bonded to hydrogen,
is obtained in part
negative charge on nitrogen.
I will mark it in green.
There will be partial
negative charge on nitrogen
and a partial positive charge for hydrogen.
Oxygen, as we have always said
is electronegative,
therefore there is a partial negative charge.
The partial negative charge of this oxygen atom
will be attracted to the partial
positive charge of this hydrogen atom
and thus a hydrogen bond will be obtained.
The same will happen with this hydrogen,
the electrons are attracted to this nitrogen atom,
this nitrogen, which
attracts the electrons
and forms a hydrogen bond.
And here we have hydrogen
with a partial positive charge,
because his electrons are attracted to the nitrogen atom.
Here we have oxygen
with a partial negative charge.
They will be attracted to each other.
It's a hydrogen bond.
The same happens between this nitrogen atom and this hydrogen atom,
also - between this oxygen atom and this hydrogen.
Here's how cytosine and guanine bind
and tymine and adenine are linked.
We talk about it
in the general video about DNA.